i don't know why i thought it was a good
idea to shoot outdoors
it's super windy and it looks like it's
about to rain
genius as always i'm doing a q a
it's a little weird not gonna lie i'm
not used to shooting q and a's
outdoors
it's people playing baseball over there
i'm already getting distracted alright
let's start with some
japan related questions do you know or
do you feel as if your japanese fan base
have grown since you officially moved to
japan what is your goal or mission you
were interested in
yeah i noticed a few people actually
a few more japanese people are watching
now that is not my intention
go away
i'm joking i said this before but big
reason why we like it here is because
damn they're really good it's because no
one knows this it makes it nice and easy
it's not like people were weird in the
uk or anything but
you kind of have to put up a little bit
of a
guard when you're out and about if
people know who you are like are people
eavesdropping which people definitely do
all the time are people looking at me
are they going to come and say hi
like you just become aware of other
people here i just can let all of that
go and that's very liberating and that's
one of the reason we like it here so no
i'm not trying to grow in a japanese
audience
but you are welcome i'm joking by the
way
what's your philosophy for being
satisfied with yourself
this sounds so deep saying outdoors as
well
uh
to be satisfying yourself
is something the greeks figured out they
understood that virtue is in doing you
can always be better at anything i'm
going back this training this is a
failure
you can always be better at anything but
as long as you're trying or taking steps
you have to be satisfied with that for
example i'm learning japanese
it's kind of frustrating how far away i
am and looking at the bigger picture
yeah i feel
not satisfied about it like i could be
better
but i'm learning and i'm studying so
what am i going to do just feel about it
all the time you know i meet people that
are always so talented and they know all
these different things but you know you
compliment them and it's always maybe
it's just a natural reaction but people
are generally
like oh i could be better or oh i wish i
was this you know these people are so
good but it's like
i don't believe in that mindset because
then you're always going to feel [ __ ]
for no reason if you're trying
then what else can you do
right
there's no reason everyone will always
feel they have that mentality so that's
the secret his hair is uh trying against
me now i got to go back this is a
failure marseille was like bring an
umbrella
maybe i can find a shelter somewhere
i'm committed to this video now i don't
care do you have any more goals or
ambitions lately or just mainly chilling
now
i don't know
my goals have definitely changed a lot
and i think that's a thing that has
happened over time where
i used to be so focused on youtube but
then i sort of transitioned my heart my
interest and hobbies into my videos like
reading and working out
then youtube has just progressively
become less and less of priority which
i've always
felt was really healthy for me if you're
only preoccupied with one thing then
that one thing is just gonna be what
dictates your mood and your behavior and
i think you end up sort of being trapped
by it if that's the case
so although my ambitions have changed
i still have them very much has
everything lived up to your expectations
what are the ups and downs of this
change
the only downs is that we're further
away from family and for friends but
both of them have been super supported
and they understand why we made this
move
so it's not the end of the world i think
a lot of people come to japan with this
mindset that everything is perfect and
nothing can go do wrong i haven't come
in with that mindset but so far nothing
has really let me down i think both me
and myself were talking about the other
day we were both thinking like there's
nothing that's made you feel like oh
damn it oh that was difficult oh that
was annoying there are those moments but
it doesn't it hasn't changed our
perception of living here it's honestly
just been really really good for us
i think the rain stopped
now that you're not a heavy drinker
anymore do you get bored at times being
sober i don't think it's possible to
have fun being sober i feel like people
say that
and this is one of those things that
people repeat to justify themselves
drinking it's not true at all that's
completely bullsh
i think i dropped my i think i dropped
my key my pocket was open
hold up
that
we're good i found it yeah stop saying
like that it's not true
was it difficult to find housing that
was comfortable space wise in japan
it's dangerous abundant
be careful
i kind of have to check this out though
yeah myanmar said we looked for a long
time for a property our original plan
was to get a flat or something like that
oh this is awesome
so we could rent it out
well we and just come here as holidays
because we would visit here every year
um
but then we looked at a lot of places
and you've probably seen videos of
people doing tours of like their mini
japan house emma tokidoki
has a really famous one where she can
touch both sides of
her walls
it's super cramped
but we found an amazing house that we
just fell in love with and that's when
we started thinking okay what if we
actually like
stayed here for longer what would that
look like and that became a long process
of trying to figure that out but yeah if
you're moving here you're likely to have
to adjust to a much smaller space but
then japan or as at least tokyo is kind
of built around going out you know
there's restaurants everywhere there's
services everywhere there are things to
utilize
if you're meeting up with friends i mean
you don't typically go out to
people's houses you go outside to a
restaurant where they have a comfortable
space for you so
you know it's built around that problem
i would say how do you take criticism
and similar situation whenever you give
a controversial opinion on a video in my
perspective you remain in a positive
mindset no matter what anyone says
i don't think i give them any
controversial opinions that often but if
to answer criticism
i mean i've been doing youtube 10 years
sure you see stupid comments criticizing
you every once in a while and you your
natural instinct is to defend yourself
or like make a point against them uh but
i think that's a really dangerous thing
to do because what ends up happening is
you just become sour you don't change
anyone's mind at the end of the day
you waste time and energy it's just
better to question sort of why people
are criticizing you to begin with and i
imagine their situation i guess you can
you can imagine their situation
why do you care what someone online says
about one certain thing you know why is
that important to them
and that sort of puts their perspective
in question and i think that's
that gives you some distance to it
because i nothing
nothing is that important
in my opinion
i feel like that was a very big answer
but yeah hopefully it's all right have
you ever felt some sort of imposter
syndrome if so how do you deal with it
see i see a lot of streamers talk about
this and i can't relate
i know that makes me sound like the
biggest douchebag i think i got so much
validation from you guys
and other people that i never question
it if anything i got too much i have too
much confidence in a lot of things
but i try to embrace that honestly
i don't like feeling [ __ ] by myself okay
when i had 50 subs people were going
like oh you're gonna become big and i
was like yeah
but yeah yeah
but i was very secretive about my
ambitions you know i never said i'm
gonna
i kept imagining like what if i became
like the biggest channel in sweden that
would just be like
insane
um but i never said that out loud i
don't know i'm the kind of person that i
don't like to say my goals out loud but
because people are so supportive i never
felt it so i just listen to people okay
at least the ones that say nice things
i'm gonna have to go a little further
away for this question
oh god can i do this
this is awesome
all right
i heard that japan has one of the most
xenophobic cultures but from your vlogs
it seems like they're all nice why the
misconception i'm not saying it doesn't
exist
but watching other people who lived here
longer i've watched a lot of interviews
and a lot a lot of what a lot of people
say is that as long as you follow the
social rules here and there are many
hidden social rules of how you should
behave and conduct yourself which can be
a bit daunting but you get the hang of
it
as long as you follow that
they treat you like anyone else i don't
i really believe so
again that's not to say it doesn't exist
but another point to that is
hearing so much about
what this country does poorly like
about women and
yeah xenophobia
and other issues
hearing about that before we came here i
just kind of
felt like i needed to shield myself
almost and marzia like brace for
something bad to happen and every single
time i was just proven wrong with my
negative pre-notion of things so i just
decided that yes i'm aware there are bad
things in this country trust me but i'm
not gonna let that dictate my mindset on
things if that makes sense i think this
is a waste of
energy if you assume the worst i think
the worst will happen as well
that seems a bit like victim blaming i
don't know this [ __ ] win man
basically i just let go of what everyone
told me about japan is bad and i felt
like it's all been positive so far i
should let my own experience dictate how
i feel about things now that mr beast
has 100 million subscribers congrats uh
do you think he will ever pass you what
what do you think of it yeah he
definitely will
come on i've been retired for like two
years now
i can't wait for it to be over his fans
are infiltrating my comments i guess i'm
getting a taste of my own medicine
that's all right he definitely deserves
that i hope he does that uh will there
be more book reviews a lot of people ask
this honestly when i first moved here i
refocused all my energy on learning
japanese before i did both reading and
studying because i think those are
activities that you know they're fun
don't get me wrong but they still take a
little bit of effort to get into but
yeah i finally started prioritizing
reading a little bit as well because i
don't want to lose that
so yeah
there will be more coming up i've always
been in how you keep your swedish
traditions even when you haven't lived
in sweden in a long time i mean i grew
there i grew up there i lived there 20
something years it leaves an impact on
you whether you like it or not
have you ever forgotten parts of the
swedish language even the tiniest bit
well
sometimes i doubt myself with like slang
i'm like do people say that anymore and
you feel kind of boomery and sometimes
you get stuck on words and you start
speaking being a bit swinglish but no i
speak to my parents every week
that's never an issue i should probably
read more books in swedish now i think
about it that would probably help i do
feel more versed in english at this
point which is kind of odd even when i
speak to joel
rooney we both usually speak english to
each other and then we catch ourselves
and we're like oh yeah we could speak
swedish right now and then we switch and
we're both kind of like
but i wish we were speaking english it's
easier
because he's in a similar situation as i
have lived abroad a long time okay this
is an interesting one is it hard hearing
about problems of your fans so
frequently
across so many platforms i see and hear
people say they wouldn't be here without
exo-nc streamer youtuber
yeah people are very open up to
strangers online
it's interesting
do you think this contributes to the
pressure of creator burnout the feeling
of fans depending on me so i can't stop
does it make me seem like an [ __ ] if
i say no it's hard to believe comet's
like that even though it is flattering
in a sense to know that you helped
someone but i don't really i find it
hard to take it seriously i don't know
why like how much can someone's video do
for someone
i don't know
but i also get it as a person you
connect with online in a sense to answer
the question about what causes burnout
though i think it's the it's like if you
have a job and your
evaluation is constantly quantified and
compared to everyone else you're working
with and then there's this large group
of people that follow it intently
it makes you feel like you always have
to perform no matter what and you do
also have to do that based on the
algorithm
you know my videos have definitely
decreased since i stopped uploading so
much so there's always that lingering
pressure of doing more i think a lot of
people said this like you make a video
you work hard on it you upload it and
there's not much time to savor until you
need to produce another one and then
another one and then another one and
that goes on forever as long as you're a
youtuber and i think that gets too much
for many people it has for me in the
past when i was shooting a tv show in la
and trying to make vlogs at the same
time
it was too much for me i could i felt
like i wasn't having fun anymore and
watching your latest videos it really
feels like you took the lessons from
philosophy and studied and found
liberation peace and happiness looking
back now
which works
do you feel had been the most
influential in helping you attain your
present state the first sort of
philosophy that i read was buddhism
and it kind of opened my eyes to
self-control and that felt very
empowering to me because i never even
thought about it before you know why
should i purposely abstain from
something if it gives me uh joy i guess
you know and that taught me habits on
improving my health working out but i
think the most influential work is
definitely the greeks
i used to so often get frustrated and so
often get i guess a little sad i guess
over things and i really don't anymore
and i almost felt like that makes you
crazy or psychotic or
psychopathic i feel like it's more
you still feel those things but then you
question yourself why is this so
important to me because a lot of times
we i think we get worked up over things
that in
in the grand scheme of things
really don't mean a lot
uh you lose your keys you get upset
because obviously that's annoying but
then you think what's what's the worst
side of this you know
is this going to radically change my
life in a negative way no
and those kind of small things happen
all the time and i think sometimes i
even fast forward my thinking and think
okay am i gonna care about this tomorrow
a lot of times the answer is no
so why should i let it ruin
the moment now you know and i think that
sort of mindset helps keep a more stable
mind but i think it also works for
harder things with loss and
bigger issues as well
again solar system being about things
you can control and what you can't
control
i haven't experienced anything like that
so
i'll have to put my uh virtue to test
when that time comes i think the general
gist is that nothing is that important
we think things are important and other
people tell you things are important but
they're not
why your channel is not growing faster
[ __ ]
but
um yeah i'm not uploading as much i was
thinking even if i should make a new
channel or something because people come
to my channel and they're like why did
you not have more
but
again
it's not that important it doesn't
matter i don't i don't feel like i need
to prove myself to anyone at this point
what did you feel you really started to
care about your health i kind of
answered this
and what motivates you to stick to a
routine i want to start getting healthy
but sometimes it's super hard to stick
to a routine
yeah again the greeks understood this
virtue is a habit
you make habits out of anything and that
can work both ways creating good and bad
habits
you know you do one bad thing you should
be aware that okay well i shouldn't turn
this into a second time because if you
do it once it's very easy to do again
but
that works both ways you know if you
start doing something positive for
yourself you can start building those
habits it's like what i said before
virtue is in doing and that's why you
shouldn't feel bad if you haven't
reached a goal in my opinion but i
understand it's difficult to get started
there's like the 30 30 day rule right
you need at least 30 days to create a
habit i think that's someone figured out
that's the sweet spot so being aware of
that starting off okay i'm gonna do this
for 30
days or maybe just two weeks i don't
know and then
at that point reevaluate okay can i keep
doing this uh what would i change what
would i
do the same i do that with my workouts
all the time you know i'm doing five
days a week now
honestly today i'm really tired
so i'm resting today and i'm aware you
know i'm not going to do this amount
forever
but i want to keep going forever at some
degree so you changed it up i was
wondering
how it has been learning japanese in
japan the stuff you picked up and the
things you want to learn
also on rules if you encountered
yeah you pick up a lot just from being
here it definitely makes it a lot easier
there's so many unwritten rules one that
i realized right away is that they keep
money in like big wallets you're not
supposed to fold the money i think
that's very it's supposed to be rude i
understand that you know you hand over
someone a crinkled up
piece of cash it's not very nice so you
always keep them nice and neat and you
always have to hand things over with two
hands
otherwise it's kind of rude which is
something i never thought about but now
that i do if i ever caught myself doing
it like giving something with one hand
i'm like oh that feels so sloppy that
feels so rude
so of comes naturally being here and i
think it makes sense but yeah learning
japanese it's really hard um it's no
secret i'm kind of struggling with it
but i'm doing my best
so what can you do i heard that is it
hard to live abroad for so long from
your immediate family how often do you
and mars i get to see them right now we
can't see our family because japan is
still very much closed
i hope my my family can come
hopefully
before the end of the year i think that
would be really nice they're really
looking forward to it as well
so that'll be super fun to show them
around japan and why we like it so much
but that's been here before but that is
yeah that's the biggest downside
from being so far away especially since
miami have already both lived abroad for
so long nine years at this point
it feels really really
to move even farther away but again my
parents have been so supportive they
totally understand do you think japanese
people are pretending to be polite to
non-japanese just mentioned by other
youtubers
i think you mean the video chris
broadday we're just talking about this i
don't really understand to be honest i
don't think i've been here long enough
to get the nuances i do think people can
misunderstand japanese people a little
bit as sort of uh one-sided because they
are so polite you know
they might not say it but they do have
opinions and thoughts you know
we all do
uh they're maybe not just as upfront
about it as people in the west generally
are and uh i personally don't have a
problem with it reading a lot of
japanese literature and philosophy
japanese philosophy opened my mind to
the that sort of different thinking
which is really interesting you should
read it you should read uh
yeah read some japanese literature
they're amazing i think that gives you a
better idea of
the mindset because yes
meeting people
for the first time is going to be very
surface level
you know you're not going to get any
deeper deep conversation or opinions out
of anyone the first time you meet them
here but i think that goes for anywhere
honestly god damn that win
sorry for a bit of dark question okay
does life really feel hollow if you
accomplish a lot of things too soon are
you saying i can accomplish things too
soon
do you believe that life should be a
certain way or do you think it happens
for a good either way so it doesn't
matter i don't know if necessarily good
but what happens happens and what can
you do about it man everyone's talking
like i've given up or some [ __ ] i got so
many ambitions
there's so many things i want to do
they're just not youtube related you
know
and i'm yeah i'm really glad i got out
of that bubble because i don't think
it's healthy all right we're getting
dark
this may seem morbid but have you ever
thought about that not suicidal or
anything but have you just sat there
thinking about how scary and terrible
dying actually is
i've been having these
thoughts whenever i go to sleep
sometimes and i'm never able to fall
asleep and just use my phone to sleep
it's getting really bad and i don't know
why it happens
i know i'm not depressed in a really
good life with the family friends and
stuff but i get really scared whenever i
have these thoughts i'm wondering if
you've experienced something like this
and if you ever have done anything about
it
yeah for sure
i remember the first time was when i was
like i don't know how young i was but we
were watching a science program and they
were talking about how the sun is going
to explode at some point
and but you shouldn't worry about it
because that will be long before we're
all gone
but i'm like but what happens to
humanity then
that's so scary i used to have this
problem as well
that you're describing and i'll tell you
how i dealt with it i used to think that
if i make like a name for myself then
you know my life will have some sort of
meaning or value which is not true at
all by the way that it doesn't work like
that i'm the kind of person that loops
thoughts or a lot i overthink a lot of
things and yeah what you described it's
definitely a topic that i've thought
about a lot as well
and i think it got to a point where
i thought about just confronting it so i
meditated about on it i know it sounds
kind of cringe or silly but i deeply
meditated on it and it made me feel
exactly like you described
and i was trying to push myself to
really feel
the worst part of it i remember even
even the bones in my body was shaking i
was feeling
all everything all about this i was
thinking just like the most morbid and
dark and most nihilistic thoughts i
could think and then i thought okay well
if this is the worst i'll feel or at
least as close as i can simulate then it
can't be that bad and i decided i
i was just gonna be okay with it i would
realize i'm not gonna waste my life
worrying about something that's
inevitable anyway i don't really see a
point in doing that but also another
part of sourcism is you live really
close to death every single day i mean i
still think about it a lot but
it's about using it as a positive tool
to not let it overcome you in fear like
you're describing
but instead
motivate you to do what you want to do
motivate you to be less regretful or
fearful with your decisions
because at the end of the day it doesn't
matter as much as you think at least and
that can seem quite dark to think about
but it's also extremely liberating to
think like that my i said this on stream
a while ago but i also made this
decision at that point where i wanted to
live my life to a point where if i were
to die at any point i would feel
satisfied and i think it took a lot of
decisions and and
thoughts to get there but i feel like
i'm i think about that a lot actually at
the end of the day or in the morning and
i do feel it
which is very liberating and i hope you
guys can get there too as someone who
appreciates good cable management how do
you not notice the mess of cables that
simulate everywhere when you go outside
of japan
uh well they're not here but yeah i
think a lot of it looks very pretty but
i'm not gonna lie there are some roads
that look horrendous because of all the
cables it's not like it's all so perfect
everywhere if you wanted to go a little
philosophical about cables for a minute
i think there is uh there's something
about it feeling like it's been dealt
with i think if i see a bunch of cables
that are just messy i feel like that
needs to be dealt with and if you do
then it's just done you know you don't
have to worry about it again
that's what i see so seeing the cables
here they don't look messy
there's a lot of them obviously but they
look tidy up because you know someone
put them deliberately in a certain place
i think you can sort of trick your brain
into thinking that you've dealt with a
lot of things kind of like the question
earlier about that if i ever have those
kind of thoughts again i can go back and
say no no i already
you know i already addressed this i
think it's the same thing when you kind
of have a lot of stuff to do and it's on
your mind and you get stressed out
because you're constantly thinking about
it but sometimes you just write it down
and even though you haven't done
anything you still feel like okay i've
dealt with it i think it's the same sort
of principle your brain can be kind of
an [ __ ] so you gotta trick your brain
sometimes into thinking that you've done
certain things even though you haven't
because you literally can't was i
talking about cables
uh what's it like being famous for
basically your entire adult life how
does it affect the relationship and such
is that the cop
i'm getting out of here
yeah there's no secret i don't like
being famous
i'm too awkward and introverted okay it
does make relationships not
relationships necessarily for me at
least with martial i think i was lucky
but uh
friendship can be awkward because of it
i actually feel like i developed a
really good skill at understanding
people's intentions
just based on youtube
because when i started off youtube i was
very naive
thinking everyone had the best
intentions when they did not absolutely
not and i met a lot of rotten eggs
uh during my time
but i
i don't know why because i'm so socially
awkward in a lot of ways but for some
reason i'm really really good
and i feel confident saying that i'm
really good at reading people's
intentions so that's just a skill that
you learn but it can be really awkward
to navigate i think a weird story i was
remembering about the other day was when
i was being interviewed for one of the
first times there was like a live stream
and i was over the moon you know i came
into this interview i was like oh people
they want to interview me that's so cool
i'm so flattered and it was a great
interview you know they were actually
really nice to me and i was so so
soaked and happy afterwards i was like
oh that's so cool but then i watched the
the full clip you know the full live
stream and their intentions were
actually to
make fun of me at the beginning because
they didn't like some upcoming youtuber
i guess i don't know they had like
a bad perception of me
but it never crossed my mind at all that
people would have bad intentions like
that and uh yeah i guess they changed
their minds when they met me but
but that's that's the way it goes when
you're uh someone that people know you
know people have different opinions
about you even before you met them and
that's gonna happen no matter what but i
actually liked how i approached that i
didn't change anyway because of it i
hope i can keep doing that uh do you
ever have anxiety if so how do you deal
with it anxiety is something i deal with
on a daily basis it really affects how
much
i accomplish with love sometimes i'm not
entirely sure too much about anxiety i
do feel anxious sometimes
the best thing you can do is working out
i think that's part of the reason why i
like it so so much and why i do it's
probably more than i need to
that's the best tip i can do i try to
always be analytical with my thoughts
you know why am i feeling a certain way
why am i
like this or like that and sometimes i
don't come up with an answer sometimes
your subconscious i've just
i don't know you're feeling overwhelmed
for whatever reason and it's hard to
pinpoint exactly what that is and i
think that's when exercising can really
just help you clear your mind and reset
your brain for the day every single time
i feel anxious and i work out i feel
better afterwards
so it's something i take a lot of joy in
cool that was all the questions thanks
for watching this q a guys
see in the next one
quick word from sponsor to celebrate me
moving to japan opera gx the greatest
browser of all time has made
a surprise for me
uh with opengl errors apparently i think
that's actually on my end
uh we got the pewdiepie bird
this is how we arrived in our private
jet that has a pool
oh this is the team that built it sick
so opera diaz has this thing called the
gamer house or something it's so funny i
love it so they built me one in
minecraft
oh my recording studio let's go
yes it's like i'm walking in on myself
hey we got the pewdiepie videos
let's go
so a feature that is amazing
and with the opera gx it's just change
of themes which you can change
oh that's so cool they work how do they
do that
you can change your theme of your
browser and they all look sexy as hell i
would recommend the pewdiepie one which
you can use by downloading opera gx in
the link description but they have a ton
of other cool stuff as well this is so
cool
all right where does this go
of course another great feature about
the rigs is the sidebar
you want to use spotify one click away
baby it's always there you want to use
discord one click away
twitch one click away what's that always
there it's super convenient honestly
game changer i feel like other browsers
are starting to copy it but they are on
top of opera gx is on top of all the new
features love it
love the sidebar
this is how hot your cpu will be without
gx control
do you hate your computer or something
why are you letting your computer suffer
for no reason just activate gx control
baby
you can limit your ram usage hot tab
killer amazing feature find out which
tabs are the ones that take up the most
of your computing power
cpu limiter as well
incredible feature oh my god sven
and
darksvan
oh oh what is that
you made it all the way to japan
yes
oh you guys get your own big screen
oh my god it's jurgen
yes
we made it all the way to japan
i got my japanese cars gx cookie cleaner
oh my god sushi conveyor belt i love it
let's clear those cookies
yeah i get those cookies cleared
gs oh nice should we play
[Music]
it is not super necessary but god damn
is it nice that it's there
let's check out the gx corner baby
so we have the ability of course to turn
dark mode
on or off whoa what's gonna happen
i was sick
hey we got the pewdiepie
opera gx theme beautiful
one of the finest looking one i got if i
say so myself they also have the ability
to force dark mode some websites are
sociopaths and they don't allow dark
mode opera gx says no dogmo protect the
gamer's precious designs they also have
a feature to check out my latest videos
if you use the link in the description
that latest version of the download will
have an animated theme as well so
definitely check that out so if you
already have opera downloaded i
recommend checking out the animated
theme they have a ton of great animated
other themes the game suggestion feature
i personally found a ton of great games
through and people ask hey how did you
find this game when i'm like
it's a
secret it sounds like such a fake
commercial it's actually true it does
happen that's such a cool idea i love
this thank you opera gx i highly
recommend checking out link is in the
description to download it's available
on your phone as well which i recommend
as well
because it's really easy to send files
through your phone they didn't show that
but they have a feature where you can
share files from your phone to your
computer super easily if you have the
browser and
that's the end of the sponsored segment
believe it or not this was a sponsored
segment